[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيلا
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى البدايه من واشنطن وتحديدا
من البيت الابيض
لمواجهه القوات الروسيه وحلفائها وفي
موسكو المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
تقول ان الاوروبيين لا يفهمون ان الولايات
المتحده تزرهم الى حرب كبيره وان عليهم ان
يتذكروا انها كانت هي المستفيده من
الحربين العالميتين وفي بيروت ازمه
التحقيق في انفجار المرفق تزداد تعقيدا
وقرار القاضي طارق بيطار استئناف التحقيق
يحدث انقساما اخر في المشهد اللبناني بين
رافدا ومؤيد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في تحرك ان امريكيا اوروبيا منسق الولايات
المتحده ودول اوروبيه تعلن ماده اوكرانيا
بالدبابات
وروسيا تنفذ مناوره صاروخيه في الاطلسي
وتقول ان الصراع انتقل الى مستوى جديد
[موسيقى]
وفي اول تعليقا للبنت غون عقب اعلان
الرئيس الامريكي عن تسليم دبابات ابرامز
لاوكرانيا المتحدث باسم البنتاجون يقول في
حوار خاص للجزيره ان طراز الدبابات
الممنوحه لاوكرانيا هو الاحدث بما يؤسس
لتفوق سريع لها في المعارك
مع تشكيل تحالف الغربي لتزويد اكياس
باسلحه النوعيه
تصعيد على جبهات الشرق الاوكراني كيف تعلن
الانسحاب من سوليدار والقوات الروسيه تعلن
التقدم في باخمود
والامين العام للنيتو يقول ان روسيا
يخططون لهجوم جديد
بعد استئناف التحقيقات مواجهه قضائيه غير
مسبوقه تهدد التحقيق في انفجار مرفاء
بيروت النائب العام يستدعي المحقق العتلي
في القضيه ويقرر اخلاء سبيلكافه الموقوفين
والمحقق يرفض ويتمسك بمواصله التحقيق
تعهد نتنياهو بالحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي
والقانوني في الاقصى قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
باحاته ومصليات الحرم القدسي ووزير الامن
القومي بكثير يتواعدوا بالمزيد والجنود
الاسرائيليون يقتلون فلسطينيين في قلقيليه
ويهدمون منازل في الخليل واريحه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تنظيم ناشطين وتجمعات
شبابيه وقفه احتجاجيه امام البنك المركزي
العراقي بسبب انخفاض سعر صرف الدينار
العراقي مقابل الدولار من 1470 دينارا
للدولار في نوفمبر الى 1620 حاليا
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي عن اسباب
تراجع الكبير لصرف الدينار مقابل الدولار
62% اقعدوا الامر الى اشتداد ظاهره الفساد
وقال ثلاثه وعشرون في المئه ان السبب هو
فشل سياسه النقديه في العراق بينما قال
15% ان السبب وانقسام الطبقه السياسيه في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بناء على طلب بوركينا فاسو فرنسا تعلن سحب
قواتها وتؤكد زي ما هابي موهله الشهر
الممنوحه من وجدوا غو للمغادره
[موسيقى]
اذا كما كان متوقعا منذ ليله الماضيه اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي تشو بيدن ان الولايات
المتحده سترسل وحده 30 دبابه ابرمز الى
اوكرانيا واضاف بيضا لان الدبابات ستعزز
قدره كاف على الدفاع عن ارضها
فدائي اعمل ناصر اعلن اليوم ان الولايات
المتحده سترسل 31 دبابه ابرامز الى
اوكرانيا اي ما يعادل كتيبه اوكرانيه
واحده وقد اوصل وزير اوستن بهذه الخطوه
لانها ستعزز قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
اراضيها وتحقيق اهدافها الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
واوروبا متحدتان في الدفاع عن اوكرانيا
مشيرا الى ان الهدف من المساعدات العسكريه
هو دعم كيف الدفاع عن ارضها ان ذلك لا
يمثل تهديدا هجوميا لروسيا
يونايت
الولايات المتحده واوروبا متحده بالكامل
الامر يتعلق بمساعده اوكرانيا على الدفاع
عن اراضيها وحمايتها ولا يمثل تهديدا
هجوميا لروسيا ما من تهديد الهجوم روسيا
لو عاد الجنود الروسي الى بلادهم لن انتهت
الحرب اليوم وهذا ما نريده نهايه الحرب
ت الحكومه الالمانيه رسميا انها وافقت على
ارسال هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا ونحن
نتحدث عن دبابات لبرد هذه المره وقال
المستشار الالماني انه يجب العمل بشكل
وثيق مع الحلفاء لتسليم المعدات العسكريه
الضروريه الى اوكرانيا وان قرار الانتظار
الذي تم اتخاذه للتنسيق والتعاون الدولي
بشان تسليمي معدات لاوكرانيا كان صحيحا
او 55
دبابات القتال الرئيسيه
لاوكرانيا هذا القرار كان نتيجه مشاوره
مكثفه مع حلفائنا وشركائنا الدولي اريد ان
اقول صراحه انك قرار الانتظار الذي تم
اتخاذه للتنسيق والتعاون الدولي بشان
تسليم معدات الاوكرانيا كان قرارا صائبا
اما اوكرانيا
حلف الدبابات الكبير على حد وصفه سفيرك في
برلين قال الرئيس الاوكراني
دبابات ابرامز تشكل خطوه مهمه على طريق
النصر وان العالم الحري يتحد بشكل غير
مسبوق بهدف تحرير
تستعد لروسيا عدوان الجديده بالقوه التي
استطاعت حشدها ويقوم المحتلون بالفعل
بزياده الضغط على باخموت ومناطق اخرى
السفاره الروسيه في برلين المانيا التاريخ
بدورها اعتبرت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات المانيه وجزء من
مخطط مسبق لشن حرب على روسيا
وقد اجريت قبل قليل مقابله مع الناطق
باسمي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه الجنرال
لابات رايدر وسالته اولا عن اسباب التغيير
في الموقف الامريكي بشان تزويده اوكرانيا
بدبابات قتاليه
ينضم الينا من البنتاجون على العقيده
رايدر المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اهلا بك سيد بات سيد بات ما
الذي دفع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
حسن موقفها باتجاه امداد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ابرامز
شكرا شكرا
كما تعلمون
فان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلفائنا
الدوليون وشركائنا تعملوا بتعاون وثيق مع
اوكرانيا ونعمل سويه خلال كل فتره الحرب
والغزو الروسي غير المشروع
اوكرانيا ونقدم لها المساعدات العسكريه
ولو نظر الوضع الحالي في الساحات المعارك
ونرى ان ال ال مساعدات الطلبات اوكرانيا
للمساعدات الامنيه درسنا انواع القدرات
التي يحتاجونها ليس فقط للدفاع عن اراضيهم
بل ايضا الاستعاده اراضيهم التي منهم
وبالتالي هذا قرار همم تتعلق بزياده
القدرات
والدفاعات الجويه والدرعيه وان وزير
الدفاع
تتشاور مع حلف وما اوكرانيا قبل ان يتخذ
هذا القرار
تقديم هذه الدبابات ام 1 لاعطائهم هذه
الميزه في ساحات المعارك من المهم ان نفهم
بان سنقدم دبابات جديده من نوع ام واحد
وهذه تكون خارجه من المعمل فورا
اشهر
التعاون معه اوكرانيا انه يقدم لهم
التدريب على هذه الدبابات
والتوفيق كل اللوجستيات اللازمه لتشغيل
مثل هذه الدبابات المتقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت لديها
مخاوف من امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه هجوميه
وهذا تبدل كيف تبدل الامر يعني ما الذي
اختلف الان
ورجان مره اخرى
وحوار المستمر مع اوكرانيا ومع خلفائنا
الدوليين والشركائنا عندما يتعلق مساعدات
الامنيه التي نقدمها لذلك عندما ننظر الى
الوضع في ساحه المعركه حاليا هناك بعض
القدرات التي يحتاجها الاوكرانيين فورا
ليستطيع
مواجهه اي عدوان الامريكيه روسيه المستمر
وايضا استعداد اراضيهم وبالتالي فان
الدبابات
المتحده مهمه جدا لان هذه الدبابات موجوده
في اوروبا
فورا ولكن ايضا مهم ان النظر الى احتياجات
اوكرانيا
واحد وبالتالي مره اخرى نستخدم هذا الوقت
المتوفر لانه لحين انتاج هذه الدبابه
المساعده على تدريب الاوكرانيين على طريقه
استخدامها وايضا بشكل مهم كيفيه بناءها
واستمرار شبكات اللوجستيه اللازمه لها
التدريب على هذه الدبابات وعندما تتحدثون
عن اشهر ماذا يعني ذلك
شهرث اكثر
نعم لا ليس لدي
جدول زمني محدده اقدمه لهذا الامر لكن نحن
نقوم بانتاج دبابات
القادمه
طريقه القيام بالتدريب على هذه الدبابات
واذا الطريقه
لها كما قلت قبل قليل الجانب الروسي يقول
ان تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات انما
ينقل المعركه الى مستوى اعلى هل انتم
مستعدون لذلك
انا انا اقلب الامر على العكس واقول بان
هذه حرب اختارتها روسيا في روسيا هي التي
قررت ان تقوم بطريقه غير مبرره بشكل غنيه
بغزوه اوكرانيا
الديمقراطيه ذات السياده
هل هذا هو العدد النهائي ام ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مستعده لمناقشه امداد
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من هذه الدبابات
ليس لدي اي اعلان جديدكم به اليوم كما
يمكن ان تفهمه موقفي نحن نركز على ما
اعلناه اليوم كم اود ان الصلاه الضوء على
اننا ايضا ومؤخرا قمنا باعلان حول القدرات
دروع اخرى مثل
المدرعات المسلحه خلال ذلك انه وصل
التعاون وثيق
احتياجات فيها من الاحتياجات واذا كان
لدينا اي اعلان جديد نقوم بذلك
هل هي قادره على مواجهه الدبابات الروسيه
والصواريخ الروسيه خاصه باننا شاهدنا
اليوم تدريبات على صواريخ فائقه السرعه من
قبل روسيا فائقه الصوت
يا سعود
الدبابات ام واحد دبابات ذات قطرات عاليه
جدا ولوفقه اكثر دبابه تقدما تطور في
العالم واما اللبد
دبابات ذات قدراتي متطوره وسيصون ساحه
المعركه في المستقبل القريب ولكن المهمه
لا نركز بالضروره
بالطريقه طريقه استخدام هذه الدبابات ضمن
مجموعه اخرى من الاسلحه اين تتحدثنا عن
سلاح المشاه عن الدبابات عن الدعم الجوي
كلها هذه القدرات لتغيير المعادله على
ساحه المعركه ليس فقط الدفاع الراضي
المنوفيه اذا هذه المساعده المقدمه
هذا هو ما يركز عليه التدريب كيف يمكن لا
يعني ان تستخدم هذه القدرات وهذه المعدات
وافضل طريقه لاستعاده اراضيهم
العقيد بات رايدر المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه شكرا لك
وبينما رحب الامين العام للنيتو بالقرار
الامريكيه الغربي دعائله تقديم الاسلحه
الثقيله لاوكرانيا للضمان عدم فوزي بوتن
بهذه الحربه وشدد على ان الروس يحشدون
قوتهم ويكثفون انتاج الاسلحه ويخططون
لهجوم جديد ضد اوكرانيا اذا هو تصعيد جديد
في سياق دعم النيته لاوكرانيا تصعيدا
يتزامن ومع ضغط دول غربيه على اوكرانيا
لتغيير سريع في تكتيكاتها بعيدا عن معركه
استنزافا داريا شرقا يقترحوا مسؤولون
اوكرانيون ان ترسل دول الناتو اكثر من 100
دبابه المانيه من طراز لبرد الولايات
المتحده سترسل واحدا و 30 دبابه قتال رمز
1 وتقدر صحيفه التلغراف فانا الغربه على
استعدادا لارسال ما يصل الى 200 دبابه
قتاليه الى اوكرانيا فضلا عن نحو 900
ناقله جندب عام
برادلي وسترايكر واموردوتما نشرها في
اوكرانيا وفقا للبنتاجوني يقول قاده عسكري
دون امريكيون لنيويير تايمز ان هذه
الاسلحه ستستخدم في حرب خاطفه للاستلاء
على سلسله من المدن جنوب اوكرانيا وتنقل
واشنطن بوست عن وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان
الهدف الواقعي لاوكرانيا هذا العام سيكون
استعاده مناطق الجسر البري بين روسيا
والقرم والتي احتلتها روسيا العامه
الماضيه
ينضم الينا من موسكو اناتولي وسيرمان عضو
مجلس الدمى الروسي اهلا بك سيد انا طول
السيد انا طولي اذا ابرامز تزود بها
اوكرانيا وايضا دبابات ليبرت ودبابات
تشالينجر سابقا بريطانيا كيف سترد روسيا
على تطوير المعدات العسكريه همم المبعوثه
لاوكرانيا
اديني سيف النصر قبل احدى عشره شهر
المنظمه الارهابيه الاوكرانيه
كان لديها الف الدبابات اكثر هذه الدبابات
اكثر افضل بكثير من ابراها او ليبارد 2 او
الشلنجر
واين هذه الدبابات الان ثم
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الدبابه صناعه
من الدول
شرق اوروبيه واين هذه الدبابات الان لا
اتحدث عن ان في اوكرانيا هناك
عشرات الجسور التي ممكن ان تسير عليها
الدبابات
الروسيه او السوفياتيه ولكن ليس
هناك دباب ليس هناك جسور ممكن ان تسير
عليها دبابات الشالنجر او لفرد او
الابرهامس وليس هذه المساله الوحيده هل
ممكن ان تنضم هذه الدبابات
للمعارك وتواجه القوات الروسيه اغلب الظن
ان هذه الدبابات سوف تدمر بالمعدات بعيده
المدى حتى قبل وصول الدبابات لمناطق
المعارك
وقبل وصولها الى همم ماذا اطلاق النار من
قبل الدبابات الروسيه هذا سيؤدي الى ان
الغرف في مره جديده سوف يفضح نفسه بدعمه
للارهاب الاوراني
اذا كان الامر كذلك لماذا تقول روسيا بان
امداد اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات سينقل
المعركه الى مستوى اخر
ده
هذا كذلك لان
بدعمهم للارهابيين في اوكرانيا باسلحه
متطوره
في دعم الارهاب والسياسيين الغربيين
سيصبحون مطرون في المستقبل ان يزيد
وجودهم على الجبهات وعندها بالطبع سوف
يضطروا الاتحاد الروسي على الرد ليس بضرب
اوكرانيا فقط بل بضرب كل من يدعم اوكرانيا
ابي
متناسبه وهذا سوف يؤدي الى النهايه همم
نفق مائي بين المكسيك وكندا
روسيا خارج اوكرانيا
اذا
بدات الدول خارج اوكرانيا
بطريقه واضحه بالاشتراك بالعدوان
سوف يكون هناك رد مناسب لهذا لهذه الاشكال
من عدوان طيب
يكون استعاده مناطق الجسر البري بين روسيا
والقرن كيف تستعد روسيا لذلك
مروج
تلك المناطق في الاستفتاء اعلن عن
عدم رغباته بان
يستمر بالخضوع النظام الارهابي الاوكراني
ومن يموله وقرروا ان يعيشوا الى الابد في
روسيا الفيدراليه روسيا الفيدراليه بدورها
التي تختلف عن الدول التي تسمى نفسها
ديمقراطيه
احترمت الديمقراطيه وراي الشعب وحاولت
الدفاع عنه لذلك اي محاوله
لاحتلال القرم من جديد او اي منطقه عادت
الى روسيا الفيدراليه اي محاولات من هذا
النوع سوف يرد عليها باقوى قدره همم
الروسيه شكرا لك سيد اناتوني وسرمان عضو
مجلس قدهما الروسي
على الجبهات اقر الجيش الاوكراني
بالانسحاب من سوليدار شرقي البلاد بعد
اعلان موسكو قبل اسبوعين لاستلاء عليها
واعلن المتحدث العسكري في شرق اوكرانيا
سورجي تشيري فاتي لوكاله فرنسبريس انه بعد
معارك صعبه امتدت لاشهر انسحبت القوات
الاوكرانيه من المدينه الى مواقع
تتقدم في بلده بخموت وانقلت وكاله تاس
الروسيه عن هذه السلطات ان القتال يجري
على المشارف وفي الاحياء التي كانت حتى
وقت قريب تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني
الانسحاب الاوكراني من سوليدار يفتح طريق
القوات الروسيه بشكل كبير نحو ضخمه حيث
تعد سوليدار خط الدفاع الاخير والبوابه
الشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه باخمود اهم اهداف
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه دنياك
ولا تبعد سوليدار عن باخمه 15 كيلو مترا
فقط وتعد السيطره على باخمت مفتاحا لسائر
مقاطعه دنياك
القرار الغربي الامريكي ليس معزولا عن
التطورات على الجبهات في اوكرانيا خصوصا
ان ريهان الروسي في الايام الاخيره تركز
على تحويل معركه سوليدار الى نقطه تحول
لصالحه في مسار الحربه فاسيطرت على سبيدار
تعني فتح الطريق للجيش الروسي المسنود
بمرتزقه فاجنر والقوات الانفصاليه
المواليه نحو باخمود بوصفها اهم اهداف
موسكو في مقاطعه دونياسك بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا فان خساره طبخ تعني ان خساره خط
الدفاع الاهم عن باقي المناطق التي لا
تزال تحت سيطرتها في دنياك وعلى راسها
كراماتسك لذلك فان الجيش الاوكرانيه وبعد
اقراره اخيرا بالخساره الامامه في سوليدار
يريد الاستماع بالدفاع عن مواقع في الشرق
حتى لو تحول المشهد هناك الى معارك
استنزاف داريات دون تحقيق مكاسب ولذلك
جاءت الضغوط الغربيه على اكياس بضرو تغيير
التكتيكاتها القتاليه والتوجه نحو جبهات
الجنوب حيث يمكن ومن خلال الاسلحه الثقيله
النوعيه التي ينتظر ان تحصل اوكرانيا
عليها من الحلفاء من شن حرب خاطفه
ستستولي خلالها على مدن مهمه لا سيما في
جنوب تونس وسباروجا وخرسون نجاحه اوكرانيا
في تحقيق تقدم الجوهريا على جبهات الجنوب
سيشكل وفقا خبراء عسكريين غربيين تحديا
صعبا للجيش الروسي مع اقتراب الخطر من شبه
جزيره القرمه وقد يجبرها على تغيير خطتها
في الشرق خصوصا اذا ما نجح الجيش
الاوكراني في استعاده مناطق الجسر البري
بين روسيا
ينضم الينا من كرامته مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج عمر انت تتابع هذه الحرب منذ الشهور
كيف تطورت التكتيكات الاوكرانيه في مواجهه
القوات الروسيه
بسرعه المراحل التي مرت بها الحرب
والتكتيكات التي استخدمتها القوات
الاوكرانيه لابد ان نبدا منذ بدايه الحرف
المرحله الاولى التي كانت الغلبه والتقدم
للصيدره للقوات الروسيه حينها كانت
الخطه المتبعه الى القوات الاوكرانيه هو
المحاوله سد الهجوم قدر الامكان والحقول
دون السيطره القوات الروسيه على مزيد من
الاراضي في ذلك الحين كانت القوات الروسيه
قد اقتربت من العاصمه وسيطرت على مناطق
واسعه من شرنيف ومقاطعه سومي وخار كيف
اضافه الى مناطق شاسعه من مقاطعه لوغانس
وكذلك في الجنوب في دنيا عندما بدات معركه
ماريوبل استمر الوضع بهذا بهذه الصوره حتى
تاريخ الثاني والعشرين من من شهر مارس
المصير حينها انقلبت المعادله نوعا ما هي
تحول القوات الاوكرانيه الى مرحله الهجوم
وتحديدا في مدينه مكاره في القريبه من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه حينها بدات التراجع
القوات الروسيه والذي اسس لمرحله الثانيه
وهي مرحله الانسحاب الروسي من المناطق
التي من جون المناطق التي حاجتها والابقاء
على المعركه في الجبهه الجنوبيه وتحديده
في اجيبها الشرقيه عذرا في معارك ماريوب
والاضافه الى معارك لوهانز ودونيسك بعد ان
يسيطرت في ذلك الوقت على مقاطع
وكذلك الامر اكثر من 60% من مقاطعه
ايزابيريا استمر الحل عاده قوات الروسيه
مره اخرى للهجوم وعدد قوات اوكرانيه
للدفاع بعد السيطره على مناطق واسعه من
الهاسكي كما ذكرت همم انتهت هذه المرحله
صحه القول بسقوط مدينه ماريو والسيطره
عليها من قبل القوات الروسيه حال الدفاع
استمر حتى بعد ذلك حين اسمع سيطره القوات
الاوكراني الروسيه على سيف
[موسيقى]
الاردنيات الاوكرانيه همم اكثر من ثلثي
تقريبا اقليمي
دوم بس لكن حال لم يبقى هكذا لان القوات
الاوكرانيه عادت ااا انتزاع زمام المبادره
حين بدات تهاجم اهدافا استراتيجيا هذا في
شهر اغسطس تحديدا عندما هاجمت قاعده ساكي
في جزيره القرم بصواريخ بعيده المدى وبدات
تهاجم ايضا مناطق القوات الروسيه في
مقاطعه في ذلك الوقت في اقليم جمباز عذرا
وذلك في ذلك الوقت تزامنا مع تسللها
لصواريخ هايمارس عاده القوات الاوكرانيه
هنا من الدفاع الى الهجوم في اخر شهر
سبتمبر عندما بدات اول عمليه هجوم معاكسه
حقيقيه استعادت فيها مدينه ليما ومناطق
اخرى في مقاطعه دونسك وعاده مره اخرى لشني
هجوم على محور جديد في مقاطعه
تحديدا
يبدو ان الان في دا عدنا الى الطور الذي
تكون فيه القوات الروسيه هي القوات
المهاجمه الايام الاخيره او الشهرين
بالتحديد همم نستطيع القول ان الغلبه
للقوات الروسيه سيستطاعت السيطره على منا
جديده كانت مستعصيه عليها حتى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه التي كانت تسيطر او كانت لها
زمام مبادره في بعض المحاور وتحليل الصفوف
وكريمينا عادت مره اخرى للدفاع بل لان
القوات الروسيه بعد تهدد مواقع قديمه لها
باستثناء المواقع التي حاجتها مجددا طبعا
هذا الطور بعيدا عن التحليل الى اي الى اي
مدرسه سيستمر هذا يعتمد على المساعدات
الجديده التي وعدت بها اوكرانيا على
الاسلحه التي سيكون بدورها قلب المعادله
ونحن نتحدثون عن الدبابات التي قد تساعد
القوات الاوكرانيه من تنفيذ هجوم المعاكس
على القوات الروسيه لانها باعترافها قبل
قليل النائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا
ماليا قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه همم في
دون باس تحديدا في مقاطعه دونيسك تقف امام
قوات تفوقها بالعدد والعداد ولا
القوات الاوكرانيه بحاجه الى اسلحه نوعيه
جديده من شانها ان تقلب المعادله طيب عمر
هنا نصائح انصحها التعبير من قبل الجانب
الغربي لاوكرانيا للتخلي عن بخموت
والتركيز اكثر على الجبهه الجنوبيه على
الارض هل تلمسون اي تحول بهذا الاتجاه
يعني فداء هذا قد يكلف القوات الاوكرانيه
الكثيره الحديث ليس فقط عن باقي
تعني بطبيعه الحال ان تكون المدن التي
بقيت صامده والمدن الكبرى ان اتحدث
مناطق اخرى هذه كلها ستكون مهدده اذا ما
سقطت من بعيد القوات الروسيه والسبب ان
ضخم بموقعها الذي يمكنها من ربط خطوط
الاتصال بين مناطق سيطره القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه في شمال الى جنوبها ونحن نتحدث
عن مناطق مثل الارض يفكا ومارينكا والهدار
وايضا كره خوف هذه ايضا بدون كبرى لا
تستطيع القوات الاوكرانيه على الاقل
المنطق العسكري الاوكراني لا يستطيع
التضحيه بها لان ذلك يعني خساره الاقليم
بشكل كامل بشكل وايضا همم كذلك الامر هناك
همم
المدنيين هنا هناك رمزيه لهذه المناطق
بانها صمدت في عام 2014
بعض المدن التي الان هي في سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه شراره انطلاق حركه الانفصال في
عام 2014 ولا 14 ولكن هناك ايضا ربما
القوه الغربيه او من يساند اوكرانيا من
الدول الغربيه لها رؤيه في ذلك اذ انها لا
تستطيع ان تخوض حرب استنزاف كما يفعل
الجيش الاوكراني مع القوات الروسيه ان هذه
الدبابات كما اشارت تحليلات لا تستطيع ان
تعود الى الحرب حرب الخنادق او اختراق
الدفاعات هي تعتمد على القتال في مساحات
واسعه بعيدا عن خطوط دفاع مجهز قبل فتره
ذلك لخطوط جهزت منذ سنوات في هذه المنطقه
لابد ان يكون هناك
شكرا لك وعذرا على المقاطعه عمر عمر الحاج
مراسل الجزيره شكرا لك
تطورات المتلاحقه المرتبطه بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا بان تلك الحرب مقبله على
مرحله جديده قد تشهد تغيرا في تكتيكات
القتال على محاور الجبهه الشرقيه يحاول
الجيش الروسي مسنودا بمليشيات فاجنر
والقوات الانفصاليه الماليه له تحقيق تقدم
حاسم في اقليم دونباس خلال الاسابيع
المتبقيه من فصل الشتاء والى الجنوب بواصل
الكريم بحسب تقارير غربيا تعبئه قوته في
شبه جزيره القرم ويرسلوا التعزيزات عسكريه
جديده الى قوته الموجوده عند الضفه
الشرقيه من نهر في مقاطعه خرسون وذلك في
الوقت الذي يسعى فيها الروس بحسب تلك
التقرير لتصعيد الحرب بحلول هجوم الربيع
المقبل باستخدام الطائرات المسيره
والمدفعيه والطائرات الحربيه والدبابات
اما الجانب الاوكراني الذي يطالبه حلفاؤه
الغربي
تزويده بدبابات ثقيله من طراز شالنجر
وابرامز وليبرد اثنين سيحدث تحولا حاسما
لمصلحته في مسار الحربه تشير وتقديرات
المعهد الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه الى
انه اذا حصل كياف على 100 دبابه في
الاجمال فسيكون تاثيرها كبيرا في ساحه
القتال ضد روس ويعتقد خبراء عسكريون النبي
مقدور الدبابات الغربيه ان شاء قدره
هجوميه تخترق الدفاعات الروسيه وتضع حدا
لحارب الخنادق الطويله ينضم الينا من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد حنا عميد حنا
هل ترى ان هنالك مؤشرات على تغيير
التكتيكات من قبل التكتيكات الحربيه على
ارض المعركه من قبل روسيا واوكرانيا ايضا
بالطبع كده المرحله القادمه هي مرحله هجوم
هجوم يعني الفريقان يستعدان لمرحله هجوم
الرئيس بوتين يريد بالحد الادنى استرداد
ما تبقى من دنيا اتسكولوجيا ويبقى موضوع
خرسون لانه عامل النهر هو حاجز طبيعي
واليوم الاستعداد لاوكراني هو استعداد
للهجوم تتحدث عن الدبابات
نتحدث عن الاليات المدرعه نتحدث عن
المسطحات ناقلات الجند المدرعه المدفعيه
الدفاعات الجويه وكاننا نرى منظومه ليست
جاهزه حتى الان فداء ولكن نتحدث عن منظومه
قابله للخلق ولكن يبقى السؤال الاساسي
فداء اليوم المتطلبات الميدانيه والوسائل
المطلوبه للاوكرانيين كبيره جدا مع
امكانيات قليله فاذا يجب ان يكون هناك
تعويض في القوى يعني تثبيت الجيش الروسي
في مكان والهجوم في المكان الاضعف من هنا
اقتراح او اا نصيحه الغرب بالتخلي عن
محمود والتركيز على المنطقه الجنوبيه او
على جسر البري كما ورد في التقرير التركيز
على الجنوب اي افضل ليا يعطي للجانب
الاوكراني من الناحيه العسكريه
اذا اعتبرنا ان الهجوم يبدا على محور
زبارود جامليتو بول هذا الامر قد يهدد
الجسر البري ماريو بول وبالتالي عزل
القوات الروسيه الموجوده على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهار خيرسون بعد الانسحاب
وبالتالي الوصول الى مرحله الهجوم على
جزيره شبه جزيره القرم ولكن هذا في الحديث
هذه في الامان هذه في المكتوب والتخطيط
ولكن يبقى الاستعداد الوسائل العباد
البشري من هنا نرى كده انه همم الجيش
الروسي يصطبق هذه الامور بالتجديد على
منطقه اوريكي بقول يا بول وهي منطقه ليست
بعيده تقريبا 50 كلم عن ذا فروجها وكانه
يقوم بعمليه استيعاب عمليه استطباق
وبالتالي تحديد مركز خط معين لانه من ينظر
الى الخريطه الى مدينه بول يعرف انها محور
اساسي باتجاه الشرق باتجاه خرسون وباتجاه
شبه جزيره القرم
الاعمده الياس حالنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا لكم انت معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
في لبنان
على قاضي التحقيق في ملف انفجار مرفا
بيروت القاضي طارق البيطار ودعاء اهل
المثول امامه يوم غدا الخميس بعد ان اصدر
قرارا بمنعه من السفر كما قرر النائب
العام اطلاق سراح جميع الموقوفين في قضيه
انفجار وعددها هؤلاء 17 ووضعهم تحت تصرف
المجلس العدلي من شاحته يعتبر ان قرارات
عويدات لا قيمه قانونيه لها واصفا خطوه
بالانقلاب على القانون ومؤكدا استمراره في
تحقيقته
[موسيقى]
بعد عامين وخمسه اشهر من انفجار مرفا
بيروت دخلات القضيه مسار جديده حيث بات
القضاء اللبناني مسرحا لمواجهه داخليه
قطبها النيابه العامه وقاضي التحقيق في
الملف
فبعد اعلان قاضي التحقيق عودته لمتابعه
الملف رغم الدعاء والمرفوعه بحقه نقد
النائب العام قرارات القاضي وافرج عن كافه
الموقوفين في القضيه ومن بينهم المدير
العام للجمارك كما طلب النائب العام قاضي
التحقيق بالمسول امامه واصدر قرارا بمنعه
من السفر
تطورات ارخت بظلالها على اهالي الضحايا
برج الحقيقه والعداله والمحاسبه بعضهم
كمان عم بكملوا جيرمون جاءت هذه تطورات
القضائيه بعد جمود شهيده ملف القضيه اثر
خلافات سياسيه بين طرفين الاول يعتبر ان
عمل البيطار مسيس فيما يراه الثاني مهنيا
وكانت الخلافات نشات عقب استدعاء مسؤولين
سياسيين للتحقيق وانتقل صداها الى الشارع
اذ كادت البلاد حينها ان تدخل في دوامه
عنف في اكتوبر من عام 2021 حين تحولت
مسيره مناهضه لقاضي التحقيق الى مواجهه
المسلحه وتم من يرى ان مسار تطورات
الاخيره يحمل في طياته بذور مواجهه مقبله
لكن محاوله انقلاب سياسي في همم عبر الجسم
القضائي لغايه خارجيه وبالتالي الامور
يعني ما بقى احد يستغرب بهذا البلد
مرحله جديده بتختلف عن المراحل السابقه
وربما ربما تمهد اكثر واكثر الى تدخل دولي
حتى الان لا نعرف كيف يكون شكله
هذا الواقع القضائي المتعذب ياتي في ظل
انسداد سياسي وانقساما حول كيفيه مقاربه
ملف انتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد كل ذلك
ولبنان يشهد اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه في تاريخه
الخلاف القضائي بين نيابه العامه وقاضي
التحقيق يرى كثيرون ان خلفيته الفعليه
تكمن في الانقسام اللبناني حول كيفيه
مقاربه ملف انفجار مرفا بيروت بين القوى
السياسيه المتخاصمه ايهاب العقد الجزيره
بيروت
انضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور بول مرقص
استاذ القانون الدولي والرئيس منظمه
جوستسه الحقوقيه اهلا بك دكتور فول دكتور
فول تنازع للصلاحيات واضح باختصار ما هي
صلاحيات المدعى العام التمييزي صلاحيات
المحقق العدلي وهل يتقاطعان في اي مجال
المحقق العدلي صلاحياته هي التحقيق لكن
ايضا الملاحقه ولذلك ذهب الى اعتبار نفسه
متماهيا مع صلاحيات النائب العام التمييزي
من حيث الملاحقه وطلب اتخاذ اجراءات فريده
وغير مالوفه لذلك استفاد النائب العام
التمييزي من هذه الاتجاهات التي ذهب اليها
المحقق العدل كي يعتبر نفسه انه طالما هو
الاصيل فان من استعاره صلاحياته ليس اولى
منه من ممارستها طيب فقام باخلاء السبيل
اخلاء سبيل الموقوفين ولكن المحقق العدل
يقول ان ما قام بها مدعي التمييز هو
مخالفه للقانون المرجع الذي يحك له اطلاق
سراح وقاضي التحقيق العدل
نحن امام
لبوس قانوني او يعني قناع قانوني ليه ضغوط
سياسيه تمارس عبر القضاء اللبناني للوصول
الى درك متقدم واسوء مما نحن عليه في
الاقتصاد والماليه العامه والاستشفاء
والتعليم وسواها ربما بقي فقط قطاع الامن
قطاع الامن هل سيصيبه ما اصابه القضاء من
شلل حتى تتلاشى مظاهر الدوله النهائيا في
لبنان
يعني قد تكون لهذه او من المؤكد ان لهذه
المساله ابعاد سياسيه ولكن من الناحيه
التقنيه القانونيه هنالك نزار هل من جحا
في لبنان قادره على حل هذا نزاع الصلاحيات
هذا هل المجلس العدلي مخول بالقيام بذلك
او مجلس القضاء الاعلى عفوا
ليس هنالك من جهه قادره على حسم الخلاف
لان هذا الخلاف والانقسام والتجاذب قد
استعار يعني الى حدود كبيره جدا واستفحل
بحيث استعصى على المؤسسات ان تتصدى له في
مكان بالامكان ولو جزئيا ان تتصدى له منذ
اندلاع شرارته منذ سنتين الى الوراء جل ما
يمكن ان نتصوره حاليا وهو امر اساسا غير
قابل للتطبيق ان ينعقد مجلس القضاء الاعلى
الذي دعى الى الاجتماع غدا واستصعب ان
يعقد اما اذا عقد فيمكنه التاكيد على ان
المحقق العدل قابل للرد عملا باجتهاد
محكمه التمييز وان يؤكد على تصدي محكمه
التمييز لطلبات الرد فتقبل الرد بحق
القاضي بثار وبالتالي يعين مجلس قضاء
الاعلى ووزير العدل
جديدا رغم تحفظي عن هذا الحل لانني لا
اسوق له ولكنه مخرج من المخارج الممكنه
المطروحه شكرا لك يا استاذ القانون الدولي
والرئيس منظمه جوستس الحقوقيه الدكتور بول
مرقص
اقتحمت اعداد من الشرطه والمخابرات
الاسرائيليه باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وماجد قبه الصخره وقال شهد عيان ان اجهزه
الامن الاسرائيليه قامت بحركات استعراضيه
واستفزازيه داخل المسجد دون حدوث اي
مواجهه
وكان وزير الامن القومي لاسرائيلي اعتمار
بني كفير قال انه سيواصل اقتحاماته للمسجد
الاقصى رغم تعهد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو امس خلال لقائه مع العاهل الاردني
بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى بالقدس المحتله وقال بن كفير احد
زعماء تحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه المتحالفه
معنى نتنياهو انه لن يكف عن ذلك لان
اسرائيل ليست محميه لاحد حسب تعبيره وقال
انه رغم احترام اهل الاردني فانه سيواصل
ما وصفه بالسعودي الى جبل الهيكل على حد
تعبيره تصريحاته بنت في رجاءت في حديثا
للاذاعه الاسرائيليه الرسميه صباح اليوم
الاربعاء وغدا زياره رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ولقائه العائله الاردنيه في
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان كما ذكرنا
في هذه الاثناء كشفت مصادر واعلاميه
اسرائيليه ان توليفه اقصى اليمين المتطرف
برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو تنوي تصديق على
مخططات لبناء 18 الف وحده سكنيه استطانيه
جديده في الضفه الغربيه خلال الاشهر
القليله المقبله وقالت صحيفه اسرائيل
اليوم ان الحكومه الحاليه تستعد لتصديق
على الاف المخططات لبناء وحدات
الاستيطانيه جديده كانت الحكومه السابقه
قد اوقفتها خلال عام ونصف من حكمها
انضمو الينا من غزه الدكتور صالح نعامي
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه دكتور صالح
من جحا نتنياهو يلتزم او يؤكد على ضروره
الابقاء على الوضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى كما هو امام العاهل الاردني من
جهات اخرى بن كفير يقتحم المسجد الاقصى او
يهدد بانه سيقتحمه مره جديده هل هو تبادل
للادوار ام هو ضغط على نتنياهو من قبل
اعضاء حكومته
يعني اولا علينا نتذكر انه
يمينه نتنياهو وملك الاردن توصلا في ال
ببساطه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في ذلك
الوقت جون كيري الى اتفاق يتعلق بالمسجد
الاقصى التزم نتنياهو في هذا الاتفاق بعدم
السماح لاعضاء
حركه قيادات الهيئه حركات الهيكل بتدنيس
المسجد الاقصى والتزم بعدم السماح لليهود
باداء الصلوات في لكن كما تعلمين منذ ذلك
الوقت حتى وحتى اللقاء مع الملك بالامس
همم مئات المرات يعني توفيق قيامها اول
همم
الصهاينه بداء الصلوات داخل المسجد الاقصى
والسماح يعني
القيادات الحركات الهيكل ليس فقط تدريس
المسجد الاقصى بل الاشراف على تدميس هذا
الامر بل لانه احد هؤلاء وصل الى الى ساده
الحكم وهو ثمار انه حركه همم حركه المناعه
اليهوديه همم التي يقودها احد يعني انشاء
احد تفرعات الحركات الخلاصيه وحركات
الهيكل وبالتالي يعني كان يفترض ان ان
يلتزم بنيمين يتنياهم يلتزم به في 2015
وبالتالي في تقديره هو يعني ما تعهد به
بالامس هو لا يخرج عن عن يعني مجرد ذر
الرماده العيون وبالتالي همم لا اعتقد انه
هذا انه الدنيا اصلا في موضع ال- ال- ال-
حتى لو كان صادقا انه في مكان انه يلزم
يتمار بين كبير وممثلين اليمين الديني في
الحكومه باي شيء لا ينسج مع توجهاتهم لان
كان لانه كما تعلمين هو همم هذه الحكومه
اقيمت بهذه التوليفه لانها تخدم مصالح بين
يمين نتنياهو امام القضاء الان هؤلاء هم
فقط همم جماعات اليمين الدين هي المستعده
للموافقه على سلسله القوانين التي يمكن ان
تؤدي في النهايه الى الى الى الى الى يعني
من من المحاسبه هنالك اعتراضات في الداخل
شاهدنا مظاهرات ايضا على المستوى الدولي
الحليف الاول
لاسرائيل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدعو
الى الامتناع عن الاجراءات الاحاديه التي
تقوي حل الدولتين كيف تنظرون الى مستقبل
العلاقه بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خاصه ان هنالك تغيير في
القوانين التي يمكن ان تضرب القيم
المشتركه او ما يسمى القيم المشتركه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني لا يوجد هناك اكبر كذبه اكبر من
المساله القيم المشتركه ما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل اسرائيل التي
يعني تمارس القتل على بشكل يومي وتمارس
الاحتلال وتمارس القمع
وتر جرائم حرب حتى باعتراف قيادات اسرائيل
ونخب اسرائيليه هناك عشرات الباحثين في
اسرائيل من الاسرائيليين الذين وقعوا على
عريضه طالب محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
بمحاكمه اسرائيل في جرائم حرب وبالتالي ثم
تتحدث الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن قيم
المشتركه عن كل الاحوال يعني انا ذكرت قبل
قليل انه الاتفاق في ال 2015
كان برعايه برعايه جون كيري وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه منذ ذلك الوقت ايضا الاستطاله
عندما تتحدث اليوم عن 18,000 واحده سكنيه
فهذا ايضا همم بدعم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فقط ضريبه كالاميه تدفعها
الاداره الامريكيه ولم
استخدم اي شيء للضغط على اسرائيل لتغيير
هذه السياسات
النعامه الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه كنت
معنا من غزه
بحث امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني والعاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني في الدوحه اليوم فرص توسيع التعاون
الثنائي في المجالات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاستثماريه كما تناول اللقاء ملفات
اقليميه على راسها القضيه الفلسطينيه
والجهود الرميه لاحياء فرص تحقيق السلام
على اساس حل الدولتين وضروره وقف جميع
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه غير الشرعيه التي
تقودها هذا الحل
قال امين سر لجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين الشيخ انه التقى
وزير الخارجيه القطري واتبحث في اخر
التطورات على الساحه الفلسطينيه اضافه الى
ضروره استمرار التنسيق الثنائي على
المستويات كافه وتكثيف التحرك المشترك
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
سحاب القوات الفرنسيه من البلاد
رئيس المجلس العسكري الحاكم في بوركينا
فاسو ابراهيم تراولي كافه مكونات المجتمع
الى بث يروح التسامح والتعايش السلمي
حسمت واجده لامر بكل وضوح وانهت مسارا
طويلا من التعاون العسكري مع باريس يعود
لبدايه ستينيات القرن الماضي خطوه ترى
فيها السلطات العسكريه استعاده لزمام
حربها على الجماعات المسلحه في الشمال
وتحقيقا لسيادتها الوطنيه وفي غمره ظروف
الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه صعبه يستقبل قطاع
عريض من البروتين هذا القرارات بارتياح
اذا لم تعد قادره على تقديم اضافه للشعب
ولا تقوم بدور المنوطي بها فلا اعتقد ان
هناك مبررا لبقائها على اراضينا قرار
نهائي التعاون العسكري مع باريس جاء بعد
نحو اربعه شهور من وصول النقيب ابراهيم
الى سدته الحكم عن طريق انقلاب العسكري
الفطره شهدت خلالها البلاد مظاهرات
متواتره طالبت باخراج القوه الفرنسيه
وبتعزيز التعاون العسكري مع روسيا ضمن
سيناريو يبدو استنساخا لما حدث في ماليه
قبل 20 خالد
ونتحدث عن اكثر من 400 جندي فرنسي على
اراضي بوركينا فاسو لكن السؤال هو علاقته
هذا الحضور او ما سيضيفه الى مكافحه
الارهاب هناك اخطاء ارتكبتها السلطات
السابقه ربما لان بنود اتفاقيه التعاون
العسكريه لن تكون واضحه وربما لا ترقى الى
ما ينتظره الشعب من هذه القوات سعاحكم
وبركه
الراي العام بعدم تاثيره على الوضع الامني
المتدهولي في المنطقه منذ سنوات وكانت
بوركينا فاسو قد اطلقت حملات للتعبئه
وتمويل جهودي مكافحه الارهاب ورغم تطوعي
الاف الشباب في صفوف قوات الدفاع وضل نشاط
الجماعات المسلحه المستمر في شرقي وشمال
البلاد
هو واخرى من ابرازيا روسيا على توسيعه
علاقتها العسكريه والديبلوماسيه مع هذه
البلدان الجزيره
[موسيقى]
العلم قريه صغيره عباره تتكرر كثيرا على
السيرتنا لكن هذه القريه تعرضت لمشكلات
متزامنه لبعض الوقت صباح هذا اليوم فقد
واجهت خدمات عد تابعه لمجموعه مايكروسوفت
بينها اداه العمل التعاوني تيمز وخدمه
المراسله اوتلوك مشكلات في اعدادات الشبكه
عاقت عملها في العالم اجمع واصبحت الشركات
اكثر اعتمادا على المنصات عبر الانترنت
بعد ان ادت رائحه كورونا الى عمل مزيدا من
الموظفين من منازلهم على سبيل المثال يشكل
تطبيق تيمز الذي يستخدمه اكثر من 200
مليون شخص ده مستوى العالم جزءا لا يتجزا
من العمليات اليوميه للشركات والمدارس
التي تستخدمه لاجراء مكالمات وترتيب
الاجتماعات وتنظيم سير عملها من جديد
نتذكر ماده اعتمادنا جميعا على وسائل
التواصل وحجم تاثرنا سلبا حين تتعطل هذه
الوسائل دمتم بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]